hey what's going on YouTube
now when I was a kid one of the things I
love doing the most was playing video
games now I'm not saying I'm a gamer per
se but when he came to the genre games I
liked the most what game you ask okay
there's a question who's the best
character in Street Fighter you're wrong
it's actually offended
so when I was a little fat boy growing
up I never really liked video games but
for some reason I was really good as
Street Fighter so basically I was a kid
that every single gamer hated and to be
honest with you because of the amount of
times that I played and how good I was
it never really made sense
and no matter how much you would
practice for hours upon hours mastering
your technique day after day night after
night eating top robbing and getting
pissed at their 56k modem when your
websites wouldn't load you just couldn't
be you know probably one of the most
messed up things that I did after
beating someone's based on sheer luck
what boss figure took victory day and to
top it off I would never give them a
second chance to redeem themselves I
know it's an old thing to do but what
was I supposed to do I knew for a fact I
beat him by sheer luck so if they came
back to me and said rematch I want a
rematch marshmallow
but in all honesty now that I'm a lot
more older and a lot more mature to the
guys that I beat by sheer luck and I
still shove it in your face I'm sorry I
was young I was arrogant it's just you
against so mad you were just banging a
controller and storm out I just picture
you rocking back and forth asking why
why God why David when all I had to do
was give him a second chance
I mean streamliners not about shoving it
in your friend's face and being a meanie
it's not about winning it's about being
with your friends and having a good time
so if I could go back in time and reach
out my hand I'd do it all over again